Hi,
so this is the second part of my
proposed three part series on political
correctness.
Looks like I'll probably expand that,
but this one deals with the Department
of human resources policy to make anti
racism and anti bias training mandatory
among human resources staff at the
University of Toronto.
And I wanted to explain a couple of
things to you in relationship to that
mostly why I think it's extremely ill
advised policy,
but also I'm a little bit more about
political correctness and general and
also about why you should care about
this even though it doesn't directly
affect you or at least in principle,
it doesn't directly affect you.
So the first thing I would say is,
uh,
in order to talk about,
or any more about political correctness,
I guess I probably have to justify my
belief that such a thing exists.
And I can tell you have already done
some empirical research on that.
We,
we,
we did this psychometrically which is
psychometrics is the science of
psychological measurement.
And so we,
we took an agnostic view to begin with
and,
and the question was,
well,
are there a set of political beliefs
that aggregate together so that they can
be described using a single term such as
political correctness?
What are the personality and other
predictors of those beliefs and do,
how do they associate with other
classical forms of political belief like
liberalism and conservatism?
Because the Conservatives often assume
that a political correctness is a
extreme form of liberalism.
So we're also interested in whether or
not that was true.
And so basically what we found was
first,
yes,
that there are beliefs that aggregate
together coherently in a manner that
would,
uh,
make it reasonable to bring them under a
single,
bring them under the umbrella of a
single term.
There's actually two dimensions that
seem to be associated with political
correctness and one is radical
egalitarianism.
And the other is,
um,
uh,
I would say it's kind of left wing
authoritarianism.
It's the desire to use censorship and
language control to,
to read,
to,
um,
to obtain certain kinds of political
lands.
Um,
we also found out that the fundamental
personality trait that predicts a
adherence to such belief is trait
agreeableness,
and that does differentiate political
correctness from liberalism say because
the fundamental traits that seem to be
associated with liberalism,
the opposite ones that are associated
with conservatives and liberals are
higher in trait,
openness and lower in trait
conscientiousness.
And I'm all,
I'm speaking of traits in a big five
manner and there are five cardinal
personality traits.
There's lots of information about that
on my website if you're interested in
that.
But the personality predictors of
political correct belief are not the
same as the personality predictors of,
um,
liberal belief or at least their
substantive difference.
So anyways,
there is such a thing as political
correctness from a,
from a technical perspective.
So it's perfectly reasonable to talk
about it and it's not merely an
invention of the,
of the,
uh,
you know,
a politically motivated invention of the
enemies of such,
of such doctrines.
So not as far as I can tell anyway.
So we will eventually publish that.
Next thing question is,
well,
why should you care about what's
happening at the University of Toronto
Human Resources Department?
And I think there's a number of reasons
for this and the first is that it's,
um,
it offers a real world case study and
that's really important because you want
to talk about something like political
correctness and what might be done about
it at the level of high resolution and
high detail.
And so imagine if something's gone wrong
with the military military helicopter,
which is a very complicated device.
You don't want a four year olds drawing
of a military helicopter as a guide to
how to fix it.
You want a detailed schematic.
And the thing about real world case
studies is they give you detailed
schematics and so we're going to take
this particular occurrence apart very
carefully.
I'm going to describe to you what I
think it's significance is and what the
errors are in the conceptualizing
conceptualization underlying the policy.
And so we're gonna walk through it very
carefully.
The other thing I would say is that,
um,
hr departments are doing this sort of
thing in many organizations.
In many organizations it's the HR
department,
that's the vanguard of political
correctness and that's in private and
public organizations is a,
uh,
like,
um,
and,
and that it's not.
This is not something that by any means,
this is limited to universities.
And so I would also like to say that you
might want to write this off by saying,
well the university is a bubble and the
things that happen there have no bearing
on the rest of society.
And that's a really foolish thing to
think because the university trade
trains the leaders of tomorrow.
I know that sounds like a cliche,
but I mean it technically the smart kids
that are in university right now are the
kids that in 15 years they're gonna be
running the world.
And so what's happening in the
universities is an indication of the
shape of things to come.
And so,
and I think the universities are in
large part responsible for the wave of
political correctness that has rolled
across north America and,
and,
and much of Europe as well.
And I think,
but I'll talk about all that at a
different time.
But I want,
I just want to say,
to begin with is don't be thinking that
the universities are isolated from,
from the real world because they're not,
they're not isolated from the world at
all.
So.
And they're not nearly as much of a
bubble as you might think.
So.
All right,
so here we're going to go to the memo
first.
So this memo was sent out to all the HR
staff at the University of Toronto on
September Twenty Six,
2016.
And it was sent out by Angela Hildegard
who's the vice president,
human resources and equity.
Okay.
And so here's,
here's the,
here's the content,
dear colleagues.
Next month we will be providing
mandatory antidiscrimination and
anti-biased training for all staff in
the division of human resources and
equity and the hrl divisional offices
motivated by conversations that have
taken place over the past year with the
black liberation collective and
racialized staff members of our
community.
This training is intended to build and
reinforce the work already occurring
throughout the organization and within
human resources.
Recognizing that there is for
improvement to embed common
understandings and evidence based best
practice within our work.
The training will be co presented by
Tina Turner.
I hope I have that right.
Principal at Turner Consulting Group and
Merlin,
Charles Concurrent Teacher Education
Program,
Ontario Institute for Studies of
Education.
So noisy.
That's the place that trains all our
teachers.
There will be six sessions hosted for
all human resources staff throughout
October 12,
2016.
Note that six sessions.
Okay.
You will receive a registration link
soon to attend.
One of the training sessions hosted on
the St George campus.
I asked that all colleagues working,
there's three campuses on the University
of Toronto.
There are somewhat distributed around
the city so that people are being asked
to come to the central campus in order
to to finish the training.
Please note that this is required
training for all HR staff at the
University of Toronto and we will be
tracking attendance and completion
versus via h,
r I s,
which I guess is obviously their
attendance and completion tracking
system,
so it's mandatory and there's much made
of that that it's mandatory.
If you have questions,
please contact Erin Jackson,
executive director Ihr.
Okay.
So fundamentally human resources staff
at the University of Toronto are now
required to attend anti racist and anti
bias training six sessions.
And they have it.
The attendance is mandatory.
Okay.
So why is that a problem?
Well,
I think there's actually eight problems
with it and I'm going to go through them
in detail.
The first problem is the assumption of
racism and bias at the University of
Toronto.
Well,
because if there's no racism and bias
problem at the University of Toronto,
then why bother with it at all?
So that's one assumption.
Um,
another,
another problem and not in assumption is
what is in my estimation and the
question of the legitimacy of the groups
and individuals who are serving as
consultants to the University of Toronto
Human Resources Department.
And we already identified them.
One of them was Tana Turner,
Turner and the other was Mervyn Charles.
And we'll talk about them momentarily.
Oh yes.
And also the black liberation
collective,
uh,
because the,
the HR people have been consulting with
the black liberation collective.
So these are people now who have been
deemed appropriate to advise the
university in its internal policies.
Okay.
Third assumption that I think is
problematic,
the assumption that anti racism and anti
bias training is the way to address
racism and bias at the University of
Toronto assuming that it exists because
that's that that hypothesis can be
questioned.
The willingness to introduce what is
clearly politicized training or,
or could easily become that into the
workplace.
And on a university campus,
which I would think would be the last
place where such things should be done
casually.
Let's say.
Uh,
the fifth problem is assumption of guilt
on the part of the HR staff.
The sixth problem is the assumption that
such training should be mandatory.
The seventh problem is the assumption
that the people hired have the
competence to conduct such training.
That's obviously linked to my earlier
point about questioning whether or not
the people who are being consulted to
make the policy to begin with,
have the competence and authority
necessary authority,
legitimacy to,
uh,
to,
to promote such policies.
And then finally,
the assumption that such training will
make the situation.
Assuming there is a situation that needs
to be addressed better rather than
worse.
All right,
so that's eight problems and we're going
to take,
we're gonna take a very close look at
each of them.
I think if even one of those problems
is,
is properly formulated as I see it,
that that's enough of a reason to
question the validity of this policy,
but I believe that all eight of these
problems exist and they're,
they're all each that serious.
So.
And you can make up your own mind about
whether you believe that once you hear
the argument.
All right,
so first,
let's start with the assumption of
racism and bias at the University of
Toronto.
Well,
the first thing I would say is that,
um,
you can,
if you compare any organization to a
hypothetical Utopian ideal,
then you can be sure that it will fall
short.
And I would say however,
that comparing any organization to a
hypothetical Utopian ideal is a very
dangerous thing to do because if you,
if you're cognizant of the history of
the 20th century,
you know that there's certain dangers
associated with Utopian political
idealism.
And that what Utopian political
idealists do is to pause it some perfect
state,
and then denigrate every organization
that human beings have ever managed to
produce on the basis that it's not up to
that level of perfection.
So yes,
compared to Utopia,
the University of Toronto has its
problems,
but we're not going to do that.
We're going to compare it to actual real
other places.
And so we're gonna.
Think about this.
All right?
So if you picked a country that was the
hallmark of,
let's call it tolerance and I mean
reasonable tolerance if you,
if you,
if you wanted to identify a country that
exemplified that above all else in the
world,
there'd be a few contenders,
but Canada would definitely be in that
list.
Okay.
So we're,
we're a tolerant culture.
And then Ontario,
I would say within Canada is one of the,
is one of the more liberal provinces,
more liberal tolerant provinces.
And it's a very,
very multicultural and ethnically
diverse.
And that's particularly true of Toronto,
which prides itself rightly or wrongly,
on being the most multicultural city in
the world.
And Toronto's a great city,
man.
It's big,
gets exciting,
it's developing well,
it's got a booming economy and a
everyone who comes here seems to get
along and that's great and I don't know
why that is,
but partly it's because the city is
embedded in Canada and Ontario and
Toronto is doing some good thing,
so hooray for that.
And then within Toronto you have the
University of Toronto and that the
campus is so multi ethnic and racially
diverse that I would,
I would challenge anyone to find an
anywhere in the world that has those
attributes more firmly in place than the
University of Toronto.
So then so I don't see that there's a,
there's a problem with with racism and
bias at the University of Toronto and I
got to point out that measurements are
real issue here,
you know,
because you have to figure out,
and I'm speaking from a technical
perspective,
what is,
how it is that you measure racism and
asking people individually if they think
there is racism isn't a reasonable way
of doing it.
I can tell you partly why that is.
If if you ask people to what degree they
have,
their group has experienced racism in a
given context or in a given culture,
they'll generally report a fairly high
degree of racism,
but if you ask them how much they as
individuals have suffered from racism or
other forms of bias,
the estimates are much lower.
And so that's just one indication of the
measurement difficulty,
um,
that,
that is part and parcel of trying to
deal with something as complicated as
racism has been.
First of all,
exactly what you mean.
What do you mean by racism?
That's a tricky thing.
And second,
how exactly do you measure it?
So you know what degree of racism there
is and you have to do that before you.
You run around deciding that there's so
much racism that people need to be
educated.
It's a technical problem and I can tell
you that if I conducted a research study
that was reviewed by the University of
Toronto Ethics Board on an organization
which are not very fond of by the way,
but assuming I wanted to do a research
project of this sort,
I can tell you I'd have to have a lot
better measures of racism then the
measures that the hr department is using
to accuse their own staff have
sufficient racism to,
to,
to necessitate training.
So that's something to think about
there.
The black liberation collective,
which is the group,
one of the groups that the UFT has
hypothetically be consulting with a
claims that you've t is a racially
biased,
a entity because we don't.
It doesn't have as many black people in
its in its faculty and administration as
you would expect to be there if you use
the census as a guideline.
But you know,
you,
you can't do that because there's all
sorts of reasons other than racism wipe
a population might be underrepresented
in a,
in an organization and,
and it also ignores the broader context.
So for example,
if you're,
if you're thinking about non-consensus
related representation at the University
of Toronto and you're going to use that
as a hallmark of discrimination,
you're really in trouble because there's
way more women than men.
Students say for example,
in the humanities,
and there's way more men in this,
in the,
in the sciences and technology.
Uh,
the hard sciences,
so to speak.
There's more Jews among the faculty or
the,
uh,
and that's almost always the case among
faculty because Jewish people tend to be
overrepresented in disciplines where
intellectual prowess is,
is valued.
Um,
there's more Asians on campus in
mathematics and say then there are the
than you would estimate from the census
preference or is the census data.
So it's like,
if we're going to use census data as the
hallmark of,
of,
of representation at the university,
we've really got a lot of problems and
we're going to have to get rid of a lot
of people who have positions that are
already members of what are often
regarded as minority.
So it's an insane policy.
Also over older people are all obviously
overrepresented among the faculty and
the administration.
But that doesn't mean necessarily that
there's,
that is because of bias,
you know,
because of bias of the same sort that
you would associate with racism and
then,
well there's all sorts of problems
associated with that and if it's black
people who are under represented,
well,
which black people are we going to try
to try who's,
which black people or are we going to
try to represent more specifically?
Um,
are we going to use recent immigrants,
I mean recent black immigrants into the
United States for example,
tend to do better than multigenerational
black and habits of the U s.
So you might say,
well,
the people who are really being a what a
bias against or are the people who are
the multigenerational inhabitants,
block multigenerational inhabitants of
North America.
And like this sort of thing can be
infinitely fractionated.
It's not helpful and will never get a
precise representation by census in any
institution.
It's a stupid way of thinking about it
anyways.
Second,
I don't think that the groups that are
consulting with the University of
Toronto hr people are legitimate.
They're not legitimate as groups and
they're legitimate as people who have a
perspective,
but they're not legitimate as people who
should be
consulted on with regards to policy at
the University of Toronto because they
are,
by no means there.
They have no legitimacy.
Legitimacy among the people that they
purport to represent.
No,
not none of the kind of legitimacy that
we recognize as legitimacy.
Like in a democracy,
you recognize elected representatives,
for example,
as legitimate representate
representatives.
So there their,
a negotiating with the or consulting
with the black liberation collective is
primarily a US group.
The racial situation in Canada and the
racial situation in the United States
are not the same at all.
So this is as far as I can tell,
it's a spill over of what are
fundamentally American problems into the
Canadian political scene.
Um,
I'll talk more about the black
liberation collective shortly and also
racialized members of the t community.
And I wasn't even sure what racialized
members mean because I guess I'm not
capable of keeping up with a rep
constant rapid transformation of
politically correct terminology.
So I had to look it up.
It's a sociological term,
which doesn't really surprise me,
uh,
because I think sociology is
fundamentally corrupt,
disciplined,
uh,
there's a variety of corrupt disciplines
on university campuses and sociology is
certainly one of them.
Racialization or ethnicized nation is
the process of ascribing ethnic or
racial identities to a relationship,
social practice or group that did not
identify itself as such.
Well,
that doesn't seem to be the definition
that the HR people are using.
So I looked at the Ontario human rights
commission website because it come up on
very quickly in the Google search and
not surprisingly because it's,
it's an appalling website and in a
multitude of ways.
And uh,
uh,
the Ontario Human Rights Commission says
recognizing that race is a social
construct.
The HRC describes people as racialized
person or racialized group instead of
the more outdated and inaccurate terms,
racial minority,
visible minority person of color or non
white.
And I mean it wasn't very long ago that,
that as far as I can remember,
that visible minority and person of
color were the correct socially or the
correct politically correct terms.
But you know,
they change very,
very rapidly.
And the reason for that is that if you
keep changing the terms,
you can keep playing the stupid
politically correct game.
That's at least one reason.
And I said I'll make a video on the
nature of the PC game,
be a short video.
And so,
but one of,
one of,
one of the rules of the game is keep
changing the terminology so everyone's
always at fault.
So anyways,
I guess what consulting with racialized
members of the uft community means is
that the u of t somehow consulted,
let's say,
I don't know how they would define who
constituted a minority on the University
of Toronto campus because like I said,
it's a very multiethnic,
it's a very,
very multiethnic campus.
It's not obvious at all on first,
uh,
it's not obvious at all who's,
who's,
uh,
underrepresented and who's
overrepresented.
But I suppose it's probably the,
the overrepresented people would
certainly be.
I'm black or white middle class males.
I suspected that people,
they're probably not very happy about.
I mean those guys are on their way out
anyways.
And males in general are on the way out
in the university.
So it's not going to be a problem if
it's a problem now,
it's certainly not going to be a problem
for very long.
So.
So anyways,
I don't think that those groups are
particularly legitimate as,
as,
as I'm speaking more particularly of the
black liberation collective racialized
members of the ut community is so vague
that I don't know exactly,
you know,
I can't understand.
I can't get a handle on the standing of
those people and I don't know how what
they did was measured there.
And,
and,
and uh,
I don't understand the validity of the
constructs that are,
they're being applied to the,
to these particular groups.
Okay.
Let's look at the black liberation
collective.
Who are they?
We,
this is from their website.
We're a collective consisting of black
students who are dedicated to
transforming institutions of higher
education through unity coalition
building direct action and political
education.
Okay.
Well,
fair enough.
I suppose if that's what they want to
do,
that's what they want to do.
It's a,
I don't know exactly what they're aimed
at with regards to transforming
institutions of higher education through
unity coalition building,
etc. It's a,
it's a typical activist group as far as
I can tell,
and as as you would expect from a
typical activist group,
they don't negotiate,
they have demands,
they have national demands and campus
demands,
and so they make demands to universities
across north America and the
universities are appallingly willing to
to kowtow to those demands without,
I think without sufficient thought to
merely as a consequence of mostly as a
consequence of fear and the desire to be
viewed as always being on the side of
moral virtue without having to undertake
the thought necessary to actually ensure
that that is where you're standing.
So here's some of the demands.
Oh,
sorry.
I have to tell you a bit more about the
liberation collective.
I couldn't find them on wikipedia.
Weirdly enough.
I know that they demanded segregated
spaces at several universities that
segregated spaces.
Can I say that again?
They demanded segregated spaces at
several universities,
including ucla and at New York
university they wanted black people only
to be living together and queer people
only to be living together and they also
demanded safe spaces at oberland
college.
So that gives you some indication of the
sorts of things that they're up to.
I'm okay.
Third assumption.
The third assumption the hr department
is making is that anti racism and anti
bias training is the way to address the
hypothetical racism and bias problem at
the university of toronto.
And this brings up a whole.
this opens a whole multitude of cans of
worms,
which is a lot of cans of worms.
First of all,
as I said,
it's very,
very difficult to measure something like
racism and bias,
extraordinarily difficult,
especially bias.
And that's a rat's nest of fear of
theoretical and empirical investIgation,
particularly in social psychology.
And there's some terrible things
happening there.
So they're very difficult things to
measure.
And so,
but you don't only have to measure
racism and bias to,
to indicate that such things exist in a,
in a university,
you have to indicate not only that they
exist,
but they exist and that they're causing
problems of a certain magnitude.
And then you have to also,
uh,
a posit that the problems that such
things are causing if they exist,
are the most compelling problems that
need to exist.
It needs need to be addressed because
you have to address problems one at a
time in terms of their importance and so
you need a ranking.
So let's say there is racism at the
university of toronto and I suppose
there is some because there's some
everywhere that doesn't validate just
because there is some doesn't mean that,
that this is where our efforts should be
devoted as a university and the
university has put a lot of resources
into this sort of thing and I think in
an ill advised way and they're paying an
awful lot of money and they're paying
the staff that are doing this crazy
amount of money,
especially in comparison to their,
um,
what would you call it?
Credentials.
Seriously.
It's,
and that's a good indication of the
actual,
uh,
what would you call it,
the actual value hierarchy of the
university.
So it isn't obvious to me that the
university of toronto whose primary
function is to address racism on the,
on the,
on the university of toronto campus.
So especially,
well,
I've already made that point.
You have to measure and define racism
and bias.
You have to measure and define the,
uh,
the,
you have to define what your training
program is going to look like and
hypothetically why it'll work and what
elements of work and then you also have
to assess the outcome and I don't see
any of that happening properly with,
with,
with the way that the human resources
department is going about this
particular training program.
And as I said already,
I would not be allowed as a researcher
at u of t to conduct this as an
intervention in an experiment.
It would violate the ethics provisions
at the uft uses to restrict to
researchers.
So it looks like it's okay to inflict on
your employees,
but it wouldn't be okay for scientists
to ask people to volunteer for,
for example.
So.
All right,
so the point here is that there's no
evidence that anti racism and
anti-biased training actually lowers
racism and bias.
Okay.
It's a supposition.
It might be true,
but it might not be true.
And for all we know that it would
actually increase it and I'll,
I'll get,
I'll go back to that.
Okay.
So the next issue is,
should employers,
especially employers at public
universities be allowed to enforce
political training in force,
uh,
a training that's politically motivated
on their employees and you know,
maybe you could debate whether or not
this constitutes political training,
but I think it does and if,
and if it doesn't,
it's close enough to it so that it,
it,
it should be discussed at least as a
potential problem.
So I don't think that employers should
be allowed to politically indoctrinate,
let's use that word or even educate for
that matter.
Although I don't see any evidence that
what the uft hr department is doing
actually qualifies as education.
I don't think that an employer should be
allowed to indoctrinate its employees on
pain of the threat of job loss and you
know,
the fact that this particular training
program is mandatory and that that set a
couple of times and that attendance will
be taken indicates to me an implicit
threat that,
um,
you know,
your,
your employment viability is going to be
judged to some degree depending on
whether or not you go attend these
seminars.
So I don't think that's acceptable at
all.
Um,
and this looks very political to me.
The,
these ideas are associated with radical
left.
Did he ology,
um,
the,
the people who are promoting this use
highly politicized language and all of
it's predicated on the fundamental
assumption that group based oppression
is everywhere and that should be the
primary consideration of,
of social policy and economic policy
and,
uh,
organizational policy even in places
like the university.
So that looks all political to me.
So this is the worst one,
I think probably.
Okay.
So let's look at it this way.
So let's say I'm an hr person at the
university of toronto and I get this
memo and uh,
here's the problem.
So I decided that I'm going to go here.
Here's what the memo presumes,
presumes that the,
that I'm sufficiently racist,
first of all,
that my membership in the hr department
is the cardinal element here about which
my guilt or innocence with regards to
racism can be adjudicated [inaudible].
The fundamental presumption is that as a
group,
the hr department,
people are sufficiently racist and
biased so that they need reeducation.
Okay?
So that to me is the presumption of,
it's two problems with that.
It's,
first of all,
it's group based,
it's group identity based and second of
all,
it's the presumption of guilt before
innocence.
Right?
So,
um,
and so that means that if I exceed to
this,
if I agree to go to this,
that I'm acting out the proposition that
I am in fact sufficiently guilty of
racism and bias so that I need to be
reeducated.
Well,
I don't think that it's reasonable for
the hr department to assume that it's
staff is guilty of such nefarious
things.
So,
and I think it violates a fundamental,
a fundamental presupposition that's at
the bottom of the western legal code and
at western culture,
um,
and the freedom that goes along with
that.
And that's the assumption of innocence.
You're innocent until proven guilty and
you're innocent even if you have,
even if there's reasonable doubt about
your guilt and you also have the right
to a reasonable to a thorough,
thorough defense.
And so I think it's reasonable for any
given hr person to say,
hey,
look,
I'm not sufficiently racist to be
reeducated.
And I don't think that it's appropriate
for you to be implying that I am and I
don't think that it's appropriate for
you to demaNd that I attend and I don't
think it's appropriate thAt you hold out
the possibility of punishment if I don't
attend.
So there's something even worse that's
associated with this is that,
and we'll get to this in more detail,
is that there's an idea that's become
very,
very popular and it's partly a
consequence of a certain brand of social
psychology associated with an idea
called a or with a test called the
implicit association test.
And that is the idea that people are
characterized by unconscious racism and
bias.
And the thing is that might be true,
but that's not really relevant because
we're.
Everyone is guilty of all sorts of
things unconsciously,
instructionally.
And that isn't how you judge the
innocence or guilt of somewhat.
And besides that,
we don't understand things like
unconscious bias and unconscious racism
anywhere near well enough or are able to
measure it anywhere near well enough to
start.
Assuming that we can start making
statements and educating people out of
their unconscious bias is it's an
unbelievably,
unbelievably dangerous idea and it's an
absolute misuse of social science,
a terrible misuse of social science and
I should say that it's,
it's coming out of social psychology and
it's by and done and the research has
been done by some of the top researchers
in the field of social psychology and
right now the field of social psychology
is under tremendous attack for the
fundamental poor quality of its
scientific investigations.
So that's all very much worth thinking
about.
So and to me the,
once we allow the idea that unconscious
racism and bias constitutes a form of
guilt and here's the road we're walking
down.
You can be punished or threatened for
the possibility of your guilt,
which means you're the sort of person
that could conceivably do something
about which you could be held guilty
for.
And you know,
everyone's like that because you know,
everyone has a dark side,
that's for sure.
And,
but we can't be punished because we have
dark sides.
We can be punished because we express
those in illegal actions.
Not,
and you don't punIsh people or fix them
up until they've actually broken the
law,
not because they might break the law.
Everybody might break the law.
So if the rule is,
if we might break the law,
we should be punished to reeducated,
then everyone should be punished to
reeducated,
and that's unless you want to be
punished or reeducated.
That's not a very good idea.
I think it's even worse is that we could
be punished or reeducated for the
possibility that we might have the
intent to do something so.
So the,
the level of abstraction of guilt here
is becoming truly,
truly absurd and it's truly dangerous.
Here's the ontario human rights
commission.
Again,
if you need a terrible quote about
something,
if you need a quote too about that will
help you support your assumption of
creeping authoritarianism on the left.
All you have to do is go to the ontario
human rights commission website and they
will give you something you need every
time.
And ruth,
virtually every sentence,
racism can be openly displayed in racial
jokes or slurs and slurs are hate
crimes.
Uh,
yeah,
well,
so much for,
for all sorts of comedians.
I mean toronto has a very,
very,
very famous comedian who does nothing
but racial jokes and I mean people love
him.
People from races all over the,
from,
from every race you can possibly imagine
flocked to his show to be insulted by
him because it's such a relief for
someone to,
to state straight out such things
instead of instead of,
and make a joke about them instead of
walking down this particular path that
people are relieved and happy to see it
happen openly.
Um,
I can't remember.
Russell peters,
that's the guy.
And so as far as I can tell what Russell
Peters does is becoming close to illegal
and you know,
Russell Peters is pretty damn funny guy.
And so,
and to think of him as a racist is
absolutely insane and you know,
and there was a comedian already in
Canada who was fined $40,000 by the
quebec human rights commission for.
I mean he said some nasty things and,
but that's not the point.
He's a comedian.
Leave the damn comedians alone right
there.
Like the gestures in the king's courts,
they're allowed to say what they want to
say so that we can keep stupid things
and crooked things out where everybody
can pay attention to them anyways.
Racism can be openly displayed in racial
jokes and slurs or hate crimes,
but can be more deeply rooted in here.
We go out attitudes,
values,
and stereotypical beliefs.
Good luck defining them,
and what will happen is there'll be
defined in a way that maximizes people's
guilt because that's the way you can
keep the pc game going.
As I said,
in some cases these are unconsciously
held.
Oh good.
So now we're going to be held liable for
our unconscious biases.
Very,
very bad idea,
especially because we just do not
understand things very well.
We can't measure the very well.
We don't understand them very well.
There's a lot of debate about what they
are and even if they do exist in the way
that people claim we don't know what to
do about it and like it conscious
retraining programs,
there is no evidence that conscious
retraining programs are gonna are gonna
fix this sort of thing.
So if there is evidence,
I certainly don't know it and worse and
if there is evidence,
I don't think the people who are doing
the reeducation programs demanded by the
hr people have demonstrated that there
are particular programs have the
positive benefit that's being claimed.
Okay.
Next is the assumption that such
training should be mandatory.
Well,
you know,
that reeks to me of again,
of creeping authoritarianism.
It's like not only are you biased and
racist and you don't get to say anything
about that,
we're just going to assume it right off
the bat,
but you better be damn well go to the
training.
Um,
and if you don't there's going to be a
problem for you.
Okay?
Well,
anybody,
if all you have,
why not make it voluntary?
Why not make it voluntary?
Why not ask people,
you know,
maybe you get a 95 percent show rate,
but then of course it wouldn't be the
real racists that would go.
You don't know that.
You don't know that you could ask your
people to go.
In fact,
you could ask them to go and see if
anybody showed up because he would also
be able to judge that way if there was
any interest in it,
but oh no,
we're going to force people to go.
We're going to impose our particular
political perspective on the morgan.
I accused them of guilt.
We're going to punish them if they
don't,
if they don't go along with our mandate.
That's the policy.
Even though we have no evidence that
this is going to work.
Okay,
now more.
Neither one.
The competence and impartiality of
people hired his trainers.
Okay,
so let's say that there is a problem
with racism and bias at the university
of toronto,
which which I don't believe and or at
least I don't believe it's enough of a
problem so that it should be like so
high up the hierarchy of problems that
we're trying strenuously to fix
as an imperfect organization.
As far as imperfect organizations,
ngos,
it's a pretty good one.
Okay,
so fine.
Let's say that this racism and bias does
exist even though I don't think the
evidence for that is there.
Well then the question is,
well,
who are the people that are coming in to
do the training?
Because I can tell you this is
tantamount to a psychological,
um,
it certainly,
it's tantamount to a psychological
intervention and so then you might
think,
well,
are the people who are conducting this
sort of intervention qualified to do so?
and one of the things you'd hope is that
they had the right credentials and the
second is that you'd hope is that they
had published something,
you know,
in a respectable journal that had been
peer reviewed indicating that there are
particular training program actually
reduced racism in a,
in a cost effective and measurable
manner instead of increasing it,
for example,
because you know,
there's always the possibility that a
well meaning intervention will make
things worse.
And we will get to that in a moment.
so we're going to look at the two people
who are being hired as trainers and
we're going to,
I'll just tell you about them and you
can draw your own conclusions.
Okay.
So the first one is tina turner.
Her qualifications are a master's in
sociology.
And as I said already,
sociology is one of those disciplines
that I at least as fundamentally
corrupt.
And so I don't think that that
constitutes qualification.
She worked in public service,
on print,
provincial employment equity
legislation.
She's responsible for work identifying
specific groups to be designated for
employment equity 12 years as an
independent consultant providing human
resource diversity,
equity research program evaluation and
community consultants.
She expertise to a range of clients.
All right.
She's the principal at turner consulting
group.
So she does this.
This is,
uh,
this is her primary occupation and she
is an equity diversity and inclusion
consultant.
She offers their offers clients a
comprehensive approach to help them
understand they're changing employee
population and client base and how to
leverage that diversity for
organizational success.
Because of course,
one of our presuppositions is that
diversity defined in the politically
correct manner is a precondition for
organizational success.
Even though I don't think that there's
any literature bearing on that,
that,
that indicates that that's the case.
I'm
all right.
Here's some of the things that she
claims and thinks inclusion goes.
B goes beyond having a diverse workforce
and complying with equity related
legislation as important as these things
are
and inclusive organization can be
defined as an organization that
integrates the values of equity and
diversity because of those,
of course are the top two values within
all aspects of the organization,
including policies and procedures as
well as individual behaviors and
organizational culture.
So in my estimation,
she's someone who fundamentally holds
politically correct beliefs and the
reason she's hired by the people who
hire them,
hire her,
is to spread those beliefs as white as
widely as possible within the
organization and now at the university
of toronto that will be mandatory and
they'll.
There are implicit punishments waiting
in the wings for people who aren't
really happy about doing that.
so
a diverse workforce includes people of
different races,
cultures,
religions,
ages,
sex abilities,
and sexual and gender identities at all
job levels.
Yeah.
Well that's one way of defining diverse.
I mean,
I gueSs I would think more about what
constitutes a competent and effective
workforce,
but that is a secondary consideration.
I would say it is a secondary
consideration at the university of
toronto,
at least in the administration as far as
I've been able to tell.
That doesn't mean it isn't a
consideration,
but we,
you,
you don't see this kind of discussion
about competence and excellence,
which is what a dick,
what a university should really be
aiming at right there.
Institutions of excellence and the idea
that excellence is best served by this
kind of diversity as a,
it's a specious,
a specious.
Um,
uh,
at least it's a highly debatable claim.
I don't think there's any evidence for
it whatsoever.
I mean,
it's hard.
Diversity is seen by the Organization
and it's employees as a source of
strength and creativity sets.
It's by the organization of its
employees as a source of strength and
creativity.
That doesn't mean it is a source of
strength and creativity.
And I can tell you I know the creatively
creativity literature very well and I
know the productivity literature pretty
well and I don't think that there's any
evidence at all that,
for example,
diversity produces an increment in
creativity.
CreatIvity seems to me to be,
seems to be fundamentally a,
uh,
like it's a cardinal personality trait
that's associated with openness.
It's also associated with high
intelligence.
It's actually quite rare and there's no
evidence whatsoever that,
that diversity increases workplace
creativity,
not,
not that I know of.
Adding to the effective and efficient
delivery of servers services to a
diverse client population.
Well,
those are stated as facts and I don't
think there's,
I think the evidence for them is weak at
best and nonexistent at worst.
And,
and that they're sorry,
that false,
those are false claims.
At worse,
the evidence for them is,
is nonexistent at best or weak.
And inclusive organizational culture is
one in which the values of equity,
diversity,
inclusion,
see,
those have got to be the only values and
I can tell you as well that those are
associated with trait agreeableness.
So basically what these,
these ideologies are expressions of,
uh,
of,
the,
uh,
of an underlying personality trait.
They're like the,
the,
the ideological expression is the
mouthpiece of the trait.
And so people who are very high and
traits like agreeableness are very
likely to hold this sort of a value
structure.
And then there are positing it as an
absolute.
It's not an absolute because there are
at least five dimensions of personality
that are associated with values that are
necessary for people to live a balanced
life.
So agaIn,
that's a specious claim.
An inclusive organizational culture is
one in which the values of equity,
diversity,
inclusion are reflected in both the
formal structure and in the informal
practices and norms.
Okay,
so her basic claim is that what she's
going to do is to come in and help you
ensure that the hierarchy of values in
your organization is transformed.
So that equity,
diversity,
inclusion are at the top.
And it's not obvious to me at all that
those are the
values that should be at the top of any
given organization.
And certainly even if they are among the
highest values of an organization,
there are many other organizations,
many other values that should be
considered at least of equal importance,
especially in an organization like the
university of toronto.
That in principle is aiming at
excellence in such an organizational
culture.
All employees feel respected,
comfortable,
and are able to bring their,
his or her,
their full self to work and have it
valued.
Yeah,
sure.
No,
don't buy it because I don't think that
this emphasis on diversity,
equity and inclusion has help employees
feel respected,
comfortable and valued,
or that that is what makes them able to
bring their full self to work and have
it valued propositions,
not facts not supported by the data.
As far as I knoW,
research hasn't been done that would
indicate that any of this is true.
So as far as I'm concerned,
it's basically political cliche and it's
ill advised at best they are then able
to contribute their best to the
organization.
Yeah,
it could be,
but probably not.
I'd had.
I don't think there's any evidence for.
And I know the literature
by the way,
so if anybody would like to have a
debate about this,
I'd be perfectly willing to,
uh,
to do so.
So.
Okay.
Next.
So this is what else she does to address
the governance needs of an inclusive
organization.
Our services include tools,
techniques,
and assistance such as assessing
existing diversity among board members
to establish a benchmark,
developing a board recruitment process
that incorporates her definition of
diversity and tailoring board documents
and statements to be more inclusive.
So it's,
it's the,
it's the dissemination of a politically
correct viewpoint through absolutely
every level of the organization.
We also provide training to board
members and offer board manuals to help
board members understand and integrate
issues related to her definition of
diversity into their decision making,
so that's what she offers and she worked
on her,
conducted 22 employment systems reviews,
so that's how widespread her influences
for a number of private nonprofit and
public sector organizations.
She also developed and delivered human
rights and here we go.
Unconscious bias training and what she
actually means by that is training
against unconscious bias and already
laid out my objections to the idea of
trading against unconscious bias.
Really like this is a terrible thing.
We do not understand this anywhere near
well enough for people to go around
telling themselves and offering their
services for sale.
Saying,
look,
I Can come Into your organization and
help your employees reduce their
unconscious bias and then also to accuse
your employees of having unconscious
bias to a degree that necessitates their
retraining.
That's an awful thing to do it.
It's,
it is the presumption of guilt or
innocence and it's the presumption,
the presumption of a kind of guilt that
no one can escape from being accused of.
It's absolutely appalling.
So conducted program reviews,
conducted gender equity analysis,
etc. So anyway,
so that's the sort of person who's going
to be doing the training and I guess
that's not really all that surprising.
Next person is.
Oh,
one other thing.
So this is tina turner.
Here's one of the things that she sells
on her website.
It's called
defeating unconscious bias.
It's a dvd or usb,
it's for the lovely price of 775 to
$825.
Defeating unconscious bias is designed
to address the hidden biases that can
affect hiring,
promoting and team building.
And that challenge,
your ability to create an inclusive
workplace.
Yeah.
Well,
I don't think so.
Sorry.
I don't believe that that's something
that can be done yet and I think that
people who claim that they can do it,
um,
well you can make up your own mind about
that.
Alright,
so next.
All right,
so the final one is the assumption,
the assumption that training programs of
this type would be effective.
So let's assume that there is a problem
at the university of toronto
with racism and bias even though I don't
think there is not particularly,
um,
then the next and then let's assume that
the people that,
that,
that we're going to bring people in to
train everyone out of their racism and
bias,
unconscious or otherwise,
then we might have to ensure that we're
going to have to buy the idea that this
sort of training is effective.
Okay.
Well no problem except here except this.
So if you're a clinician and a research
scientist say like me,
one of the things that you've learned is
that you do not put in place and
intervention without assessing its
outcome.
And the reason for that is because there
have been well publicized failures of
social science interventions,
which I would,
and I would consider this sort of
training exactly that it falls under the
same rubric because it's an educational
or a psychological intervention.
There've been well documented
catastrophic failures of such
interventions in the past.
One of the most famous,
one of those was called the somerville
study,
which was done in the 19 thirties.
A woman named joan mccord.
Uh,
a very good criminologist conducted a
lot of the,
the followup research to the somerville
study and the somerville study was an
attempt to take kids who are in a kind
of rough inner city neighborhoods and
put them through psychological and
sociological interventions to reduce
their risk of especially of crime in the
later years of their life.
And actually what happened was that the
intervention,
although very carefully designed and I
would say admirably designed and also
designed by people who I did do think
had the best interest of the kids at
mind in mind or at heart.
My consequences were that the kids who
were in the intervention program
actually ended up being more criminal
than the kids that weren't,
and there's a large literature on this.
It was a very shocking study at a
particular set of the people who did it.
It's a classic and and it's not the
only.
It's not the only study of its type.
Now I'm posting the introduction to this
book was written by joan mccord called
crime and family.
There's two chapters in that book that's
the selected writings of john mccord,
one's called the cambridge somerville
study,
a pioneering longitudinal experimental
study of delinquency prevention,
and then chapter four is cures that harm
unanticipated outcomes of crime
prevention programs.
While that could be of any kind of
prevention program,
so I'll post the introduction so that
you guys can read that,
but my point is quite clear.
You have an intervention.
You think there's a problem,
you design an intervention.
Well then it's incumbent on you to
demonstrate carefully that the intention
that the intervention produces its
desired effects because there's a high
probability that it won't.
In fact,
there's a high probability that will
produce the word reverse effect,
so for all the hr department knows their
mandatory training program could make
people more racist and more biased and I
would say the mere fact that the
training is mandatory is highly likely
to produce precisely that outcome
because it's going to generate
resentment among people,
even people who are going who,
who would be relatively unwilling to
express that resentment.
So my hypothesis would be as a scientist
and a researcher,
if I was conducting this as an
experiment that heidi to have two
conditions
voluntary and mandatory.
Although I wouldn't be allowed to do
that because that would be unethical by
the way,
according to the will.
That would be an.
That would be unethical research,
but I would test to see if mandatory
trading and voluntary trading had
different effects and my guess is that
mandatory training would kick back and
it would reverse the effects of the
training.
But we don't care about that sort of
thing.
When we put policy like this into place
because we already assume that we know
what we're doing.
And partly we do that because we know so
little about what we're doing that we
can't even see what sort of mistakes we
might be making.
We just make assumptions.
There is racism,
we know where it is.
We have a training program,
the training program,
we'll fix the racism and then things
will be better and it doesn't matter if
we make it mandatory.
It's like,
sorry,
none of those propositions are viable.
There are all debatable.
They all need to be tested and they're
all dangerous in that they might produce
a,
an unintended consequence,
a negative consequence,
and that there's lots of reason in the
literature to assume that that might be
the case.
So I'll post that.
You guys can read it.
You can think about it.
Marilyn charles.
So she's the one along with tan and
turner who's going to be doing the
training.
Couldn't find out that much about her.
Um,
she's a sessional lecturer at the
ontario institute of studies on
education.
I guess I need to say something about
noisy.
I think that educational psychology is a
extraordinarily fad,
written discipline.
I think the level of scholarship is
appallingly low.
Um,
I can identify a number of fads that,
that,
that rushed through the educational
system,
a lot of it pushed through by
educational psychologists over the last
20 years.
The idea of practical intelligence,
that's one of them,
the idea of whole word reading,
which was a catastrophe in the
California school system.
That was another,
the notion that self esteem training,
that self esteem even exists,
which I don't think it does technically
speaking.
I think it's a very fundamentally have
trait.
Neuroticism,
which isn't really movable.
Um,
there's,
there's some reasonable evidence that
self esteem training turn children into
narcissists rather than increasing their
self esteem.
Um,
and I don't think there's any evidence
that the self esteem programs had the
desired effect.
Um,
so there's a variety of,
of.
Oh,
and then there's also the idea of
multiple intelligences,
which is an absolutely specious idea
from a scientific perspective.
So educational psychology is
unbelievably fad written and so,
and noisy is a major offender in that
regard.
Um,
anyways,
merlin,
charles is,
it has a phd in education and,
and the reason I'm bringing up the fad
written issue is because she's a
specialist in what's called holistic
education.
It's a philosophy of education based on
the premise that each person finds
identity meaning and purpose in life's
through connections to the community,
to the natural world entity,
humanitarian values such as compassion
and peace,
which,
which I would say also those values are
reflective of trait agreeableness by the
way,
especially compassion,
holistic education names to call forth
from people and intrinsic reverence for
life and a passionate love of learning.
Well,
to me that's all cliche fundamentally.
Um,
and,
and I,
I sold the fact that she's a specialist
in education,
does not indicate to me that she holds
the qualifications necessary to serve as
an advisor to,
to policymakers at the university of
toronto.
So,
so why is the university of toronto
listening to these individuals and
groups?
Uh,
I Think there was a lot of reasons for
it,
but I think one of them is that it's
because they effectively present
themselves as oppressed or as experts in
oppression.
And that's enough,
and one of the things we might further
discusses what value should be being
supported,
presented out the university.
And right now the pc onslaught is,
is predicated on the idea that the
fundamental values are equity,
diversity and inclusion.
And what I find troublesome about that
is two fold,
one that that's a very one sided
hierarchy of values and I mean that
technically because it's the values that
agreeable people would hold as as,
um,
sacrosanct.
And there's other sets of values that
have to be included in a properly
function in value hierarchy,
in order for individuals and for society
to stay balanced.
And I would say that what also needs to
be included at the university are the
values associated with
conscientiousness,
which would be roughly competence,
excellence and quality,
and also of openness,
which is creative free inquiry.
And so those have to be considered at
least as important and arguably as more
important.
The other thing that bothers me is that
the definitions of equity and diversity
and inclusion are defined by precisely
the criteria that the social justice
warrior and pc types believe are
responsible in some sense.
For all the ills in society and that
we're asking,
we're,
we're being required to construe
ourselves in terms of our group
identity,
whatever that group might be,
age,
gender,
race,
ethnicity,
sexual preference,
sexual expression,
gender expression,
gender identity,
and Undoubtedly a plethora of new terms
to come.
We're being asked to accept those,
um,
divisions as,
as,
as indicative of indicative of the
fundamental differences between us.
and then to assume that the only way
that that you can judge whether or not a
society is fuNctioning properly is to
determine whether everY person where
were there,
all of those categories are represented
numerically,
equally in every single situation.
Well,
you know,
it's a,
it's a poor game that and Uh,
it's part of the pc game and I'm going
to release a video on the pc game,
a short one to define exactly what that
is.
So,
okay,
so what might be done about such things?
That would be the next question in,
in this particular case,
what should be done?
Well,
I would say that her staff at the
university of toronto
and and also and people everywhere
should refuse to subject themselves to
reeducation regarding their putative
racism and bias unless they want to
convict themselves by attending and I
think that's exactly what they're doing
is that if you're forced to undergo such
training and you agree,
then by the fact that you attend,
you agree that the intervention is
justified and I'm.
I know that it's difficult for people to
stand up against this sort of thing,
but I don't think it's as difficult as
people presume at least in in impossible
in at least possibly because I think
that the people who are pushing this
sort of thing are actually not very
brave.
I mean they construe themselves
continually as victims and I have a
sneaking suspicion that if people push
back with any degree of firmness that
they would back off very,
very rapidly.
But we need to find out because these,
this sort of thing has to be stopped
now.
It can be still be stopped by peaceful
means and and I don't think that that's
going to be the case in 10 years if
things continue the way they are,
so it's time for people to stand up
using peaceful means and here's some
ways you should contact some of the
people in charge and all of your
organization or in this case,
the university of toronto and express
your concern and you should do it.
You should say what you have to say in a
cool headed,
clear and well articulated manner.
And you assumed to begin with
rationality and goodwill on the part of
the recipients.
Um,
you can consider that assumption,
an act of courage on your part.
If you can't formulate your own words,
then you can tell them that you found
the arguments in this video convincing
and maybe you want to highlight one or
two of them.
I gave eight different arguments.
You could send them the link might,
might also be interesting to ask these
people how much the university is
planning to pay for these training
sessions because that's something I'd be
very interested in knowing.
So I think it's something that,
that,
that's,
that's a valid manner matter for public
debate.
All right.
And so here's the,
here's the connections of the people,
the contact information that would
enable you to contact the people who
are,
are responsible for the policies.
Here they are.
So the first is erin jackson.
She's the executive director,
internal resources,
internal human resources.
I took a look at her credentials.
She has a bachelor's degree with an
advanced certificate from the rodman
advanced program in human resources
management and I can't see that,
that level,
that level of qualification ensures that
she has the expertise necessary to
evaluate the effectiveness of the kind
of program that she's considering
putting in place.
So that's erin jackson.
She's at aaron dot jackson,
that you toronto dot,
ca.
And then she works for angela hilliard
who's the vice president of human
resources and equity.
Uh,
angela dot hilliard@utoronto.ca.
And then finally up above at the highest
plateau is the president of the
university,
dr merrick hitler.
And you can reach him at,
at u toronto.ca.
So I would say email these folks,
if you email one of them,
email all three of them,
express your concern,
and I would also say to the hr staff
that's going to be affected by this,
that you should make your opposition
known unless you agree to convict
yourself of your racism and bias by
attending,
and if enough of you did it,
it would come to a halt.
At least at least it could be put
forward that this program should not be
mandatory.
Okay.
So thank you very much for listening.
and soon enough I'll put up lecture
three,
which is going to be a very pragmatic
and focused lecture on tactics that can
be used to push back against the
political correct,
against political,
correct excesses.
Bye for now.